So let's try another quiz.
This one's going to be quite a bit trickier.
Here the question is, "What does the 'sum' procedure do?"
And here's the definition of 'sum,'
so here we're defining the procedure of sum.
It takes two inputs, "a" and "b,"
and its body assigns to "a" the value of "a" plus "b."
So the choices are: Nothing;
that it takes two numbers as its inputs, and outputs the sum of the two numbers;
that it takes two strings as its inputs,
and outputs the concatenation of those two strings.
So the final choice is that it takes two numbers as its inputs,
and changes the value of the first input to be the sum of the two numbers.
This is a quite tricky question.
I would encourage you to try some experiments in the Python interpreter
to see if you can determine for sure what the sum procedure does.